On parle de Jackie aux
États-Unis en tant que sœur de John Cullen ou en
parle-t-on de la sœur de Jackie's Colleen
jamais mentionnée en Amérique ouais mais en
Europe c'est un peu plus parce qu'en
Europe elle a été une grande star pendant tant d'
années ouais mais en Amérique  sais parce
que j'ai eu tellement de livres à succès là
-bas qui sont numéro un que les gens
ne pensent pas que je sais vraiment que vous n'y
pensez pas non jamais vous avez l'auteur
de best-sellers géants dans le monde entier combien de
cookies avez-vous vendu jusqu'à  maintenant mais une
centaine de millions de livres tu as raison chaque
jour oui il faut se lever tu le
sais mais tu dois te conduire à
la mort car sinon tu ne le fais
pas beaucoup de gens en parlent ils
veulent le faire  s'ils sont tous j'écrirai
un livre un jour ouais je ne le fais jamais tu as
dû demander le pouvoir oui absolument combien
d'heures sont juste tout salut je
suppose que je commence à courir vers neuf heures
du matin ouais ma semaine de droits jusqu'à
environ six ou sept et si je suis r  eally sur
un rouleau j'écrirai toute la nuit et je mettrai un
caramel au beurre sur le bureau pour gonfler
j'aime beaucoup combien de pages l'ont obtenu 10
puis j'essaie de saisir un autre âge ouais le
tennis est des lieux de 20 ans de rage et on
ne l'est pas  bien quel conseil me donneriez-
vous pour écrire un best-seller je pense que vous l'
avez déjà mais si je devais donner des
conseils aux gens là-bas je dirais que
vous ne pouvez pas en parler vous devez le
faire vous devez le mettre  vous savez le cul sur
cette chaise et le faites réellement vous savez
parlez-moi du style folk votre dernier livre
bien quelle star est un livre que je
voulais écrire parce que c'est une histoire passionnante
que je pensais que c'était une histoire passionnante à
propos de trois rock stars probablement Mandela
qui est la superstar de la soul noire raffaello
qui est sa belle fille et elle devient
célèbre au Brésil
elle chante du punk rock indien et Chris
Phoenix il est le rock anglais il est
comme ce qui est Cho art et sugar no Nick
jacket ouais les gens ont comparé
cela parce qu'il est un anglais définitif
Roche  star Je veux dire qu'il commence dur à 18 ans
et monte à 36 Je veux dire que son âge change
à Brooklyn tu le vois passer par
tout c'est presque un manuel sur la façon
de devenir une rock star tu as rencontré beaucoup de
rock stars tu sais tu sais ouais faire
les Beatles les pierres oui je suis au
centre commercial ouais pas beaucoup parce que mon mari
a toujours juste des attaques alors oui nous sommes
ad libs un athlète célèbre allongé juste
dessus c'est là que j'ai rencontré mon mari le monde
pour métal les Beatles et  les pierres et la
tige et tout le monde et c'était génial pour moi
parce qu'au fil des ans, je vous ai regardé
voir comment la liste change ce qui
est arrivé à leur carrière, les femmes de
leur vie et si un film devait être fait à
partir d'une rock star qui  un aimeriez-vous que
j'aimerais voir sting ou le
rocker anglais torride qui a les yeux d'une rock star vous
savez ouais ce genre de
sentiment charismatique quand il se met devant la
caméra je suis peut-être Whitney Houston pour la
fille que j'ai vue avec moi à New York  combien d'
argent a été investi aux États-Unis f  ou le
lancement de votre livre je n'en ai aucune idée je
n'ai jamais demandé ça mais je ne suis pas sûr de l'avoir fait donc
je ne pose pas cette question mais je
m'assure qu'ils le font correctement les choses
qu'ils voient beaucoup de très bien faites il
y a  une publicité dans laquelle vous dites qu'en ce
qui concerne la vie des riches et des
célébrités j'ai écrit un livre c'est vrai
c'est vrai pourquoi je pensais que vous saviez que les
gens lisent mon genre de fiction ils
regardent de très près ce qui se passe
réellement  va ton bas parce que si
j'essayais la vraie vérité personne ne le
croirait nous devons découvrir qui c'est à
chaque fois que tu fais un bond tu es
très oh j'aime oui j'aime le léopard ouais
je pense juste que de beaux animaux dans un
très puissant  très fort c'est bon Mia
collection est-ce que tu t'en sors maintenant
mais c'est vrai que pour Noël
ton livre a été vendu et c'est le jeu du
papier de peau de petit bot pour emballer le livre
dedans c'est vrai tu en sais beaucoup tu ne
sais pas  beaucoup d'images sauvages que nous
pouvons aligner sur un tapis en peau de léopard  avec des
vêtements et ils l'ont enroulé autour
du livre est un type spécial de Noël que la
plupart correspondraient incroyable c'était amusant même
s'amuser dans la vie et ils disent faites-en un
Noël Jackie Collins nous n'utilisons pas nous
n'avons pas vous préférez  être impliqué dans la
littérature, je veux dire, au lieu de faire du commerce de
livres, mais vous voyez, je suis un
conteur ouais, je n'ai jamais prétendu
être un grand écrivain littéraire, je ne veux
pas être un écrivain policier et je
ne pourrais probablement pas être un écrivain littéraire.  mais
j'adore raconter des histoires j'ai abandonné l'école
quand j'avais 15 ans et toi celle que je
voulais faire était d'écrire puis de lire mes livres
parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils sont très torrides
des femmes très sexy les lisent parce
qu'elles sont comme des femmes fortes  et mes vrais
fans les lisent parce qu'ils aiment l'
humour mais nous n'échangeons pas 1
million de cookies contre les Kurdes notre
prix maintenant définitivement que ferais-je
d'une surprise je veux dire vous ne souffrez pas
d'avoir autant de succès et d'écrire des
publicités  les romans ne souffrent pas parce que
moi-même  ne les considère jamais comme commerciaux
je pense que celui que je pense c'est ce que je
veux écrire quand j'ai raison je n'écris pas
rock star pour sortir et vendre des
millions d'exemplaires je ne le suis pas c'est ce que je
veux faire et je '  Je suis très content qu'il
vende beaucoup d'abonnés mais ce n'est pas la
raison pour laquelle je le fais David tu ne veux
pas écrire leur livre avec sans
recettes rien que sur toi tes
vies vont bien je Misérables encore tu
ne serais pas misérable ça  Je serais très heureux que
ta sœur ait quitté l'Angleterre avant toi et que
tu l'apprécies oui y los angeles
uh-huh tu as un géoserveur sais qu'elle était une
star de cinéma à Hollywood quand j'ai cet
enfant sauvage en Angleterre ouais et j'ai été
expulsé de l'école  parce que j'avais l'habitude de faire
signe dans les régions, c'était un
gars qui avait l'habitude de flasher non mais vous appelez
ça une session de laboratoire avant, je pesais
avec lui et j'ai dit que j'appelais tous les jours
donc ils étaient vraiment croisés avec moi les
enseignants  ils ont dit qu'il fallait se débarrasser de
cette fille et j'ai dit vrai et tout le
temps je  Ce serait dommage que j'allais dans le
sud de la France et que je vole Henry
Miller à la pharmacie locale et
que je le ramène clandestinement en Angleterre parce qu'à ce moment-là
tu ne fais pas SWAT minute euh-huh ouais elle
devient romancière maintenant ta sœur maintenant
je pense  tout le monde est ce que je veux dire toujours
réussir ma soeur est une actrice et dans la
vie je pense que tu as une vocation moins 2
ri converge pour agir qui vient sur
ton arène de chars pas vraiment je pense
qu'après 20 ans et 12 livres elle a couru
très vite en effet là  n'est pas un tiers
entre le savoir de vos
meilleurs amis vous avez toujours été la
presse aimerait l'avoir autrement
mais nous sommes heureux que vous ne vouliez pas dire
ce match et maintenant je ne vous
rencontrez pas ce métro  fan maintenant nous nous rencontrons à l'
aéroport bonjour comparaison tu vas
ailleurs tu es marié avec
le même homme depuis 20 ans mais Elliot
21 ans ouais longtemps à Holly
longtemps est différent de ta sœur maintenant
très différent quand est-ce que tu  pense à sa
vie  t um je n'y pense
pas vraiment j'écris juste sur d'autres personnes
ouais tu es inspiré par elle parfois non
non non tu as gagné le droit de naître bon
pochoir eh bien c'est drôle non j'ai écrit un
livre intitulé Hollywood mari et dedans
je  avait cette superstar scandaleuse
appelée Silver Anderson et elle avait ce
genre de petit ami qui était comme une bombe dans
hustler et Peter Home est venu me voir lors d'
une fête un soir et il a dit Oh Jackie
merci beaucoup de me faire paraître si
bien je  dit Peter ce que vous propose
cela aurait été un autre livre que
j'ai